The Joe Rogan experience,
you going to be happy living forever?
Like what if, when you die, it's amazing.
What if when you die, there
really is a heaven. You really,
really do go to some spectacular
dimension filled with love and peace and
happiness. And there's no
emotions like we think about here.
There's no fear. There's not none
of the things that hold people back.
None of the anxiety and the adjunct.
It's just consciousness and love.
And then you're wasting your time.
You're just trying to stay alive,
taking pills to live,
to be a million
boy. You open up big can
of worms, right? Bra,
I will tell you, um, Joe,
without a shadow of a doubt,
none whatsoever.
Death is not the end. You don't
think so? I know, I know too.
How do you know? Cause I've been
dead, right? Yes. I think there.
What about that experience
cemented it in your head? Um,
like I said,
it was the most peaceful.
Um, and, and I, I don't feel
like it was the most peace,
most restful, most I
was, I woke up laughing.
I was, yeah. Yeah.
My wife tells me I was overjoyed.
You woke up laugh. Yeah,
I was over to you remember anything about
what happened when you blocked out the
time? Extremely peaceful. Extreme.
I didn't have a worry.
Extremely true.
And I was not sad at all.
You know,
I was overjoyed,
very happy,
very peaceful and erased.
Any fear that I might have had and a,
and any fear of dying is gone.
I don't feel that at all. It's so, I mean,
maybe that's why I don't want to live
to be a hundred cause it, I mean,
I wouldn't mind visiting that place again,
man.
It was so much peace so much and
it wasn't like, you know, um,
this is, you know, I'm just in the ground.
I'm a and I'm not a plant,
uh,
just dirt,
you know,
I know that I'm in a very
comfortable place and,
and you know, I wouldn't mind visiting
again. I wouldn't mind. Definitely.
I hold no fear.
And so when I say that it's,
it's definitely not the end. You're,
I believe that your soul, you know,
so people have a different name
for a consciousness of whatever.
It's definitely eternal.
And then here's how else could you have
these feelings or emotions or you know,
they have that sort of comfort,
the feeling of comfort and being in
the right place if something didn't
continue. Because my life,
my life was gone. The essence
of life, my, my bindings,
you know, gone, it was gone.
Flat Line, did whatever.
I told my doctor that died and he said,
no,
actually it's called some kind of Paul's
or some shit like that. And I'm saying,
look, if the pause lasted doc, I
wouldn't be talking to you too.
So I he call it appalls. I, well,
during that Paul's, I
was dead. So, uh, it's,
it was a wonderful feeling to them.
How about I don't,
I'm not a dystopian person terms of like
today I'm not cynical. I'm really not. I,
I think I like people, I like what
I see out there in the world today.
I think things are changing
for the better. What?
I'm worried that technology doesn't give
a fuck this and the way it goes live,
it's just going to just decide it's here
for its own advancement and in order to
complete its protocol of
constant completion of this
and it's going to become a
god,
it's just going to become
something insanely powerful
that doesn't need to worry
about radiation,
cooking it or worry about running out
of food or worry about sexual abuse when
they're a child,
doesn't have to worry about anything.
So it's definitely unstoppable.
I think this wave of technology,
all we can do is innovators and creators,
engineers,
scientists is steer that way.
We can is fit while we certainly can
steer it with her now where right.
And that's the best we can
do. And those are the, that's,
that's really the best we can do is
as good people, you know, steer it.
And that's why the leadership is
important. That's why the people that, uh,
Jack Ilan, Larry Page, uh, the,
everybody at the Mark Zuckerberg,
they are defining or this
wave is going. And, uh,
I am hoping to be one of the people
that does as well. That's beautiful.
Um, Joe of can I, can I finish
by reading something? Sure.
Of a recently witnessed
because of this Tesla work,
because of just the passion I've put
out there about particularly automation
that there has been a few people,
brilliant men and women engineers and
leaders including Ilan mosque who've been
sort of attacked, almost personally
attacked by really people,
critics from the sidelines.
And so I just wanted to,
if I may close by reading the,
uh,
the famous x or from a Teddy
Roosevelt. Yeah. Okay. Just for them.
It would make me feel good
if you want to do that. Uh,
it's not the critic who counts,
not the man who points out how the
strong man stumbles or where the doer of
deeds could have done them better.
The credit belongs to the man
who's actually in the arena,
whose face is marred by dust and sweat
and blood. Who strives valiantly.
Who Errs,
who comes short again and again because
there is no effort without error and
shortcoming. But who does
actually strive to do the deeds?
Who knows great enthusiasms,
the great devotions,
who spends himself in a worthy cause,
who at the best knows in the end the
triumph of high achievement and who at the
worst,
if he fails at least fails while daring
greatly so that his place shall never be
with those cold and timid souls who
neither know victory nor defeat.
Joe,
thank you for having me on.
Sounds like you let the haters
get to you a little bit there.
Okay.
She brought the guy in Florida.
They got arrested because he would not
take I eat ass off the back window we
were talking about that I eat ass.
Eat Ass said on the back of his window.
He said it is his first amendment right
to let everyone know that he eats ass.
Yeah, but that's a funny thing.
Imagine if that's your boy.
You have this little baby sucking
on your nipple and you're like,
my cute little boy. He's adorable. Oh
my little Billy wants to play baseball,
but he doesn't like getting up early
and he misses a lot of practice.
He got cut from the team and
now he's Kinda depressed.
He just plays Madden all day and in
one day Billy's got a pickup truck and
Billy's pickup truck says I e f and you
come home and he's still living at your
house cause he's a fucking loser and you
come home and you see little Billy with
his I eat ass on. Do you really
need to have that on your truck?
In my driveway I do through mall.
That's how I get my ass to eat.
A lot of guys don't, but
I do so I love by no. Ah,
ah, I do. I do. I do. I and a dad is like,
I still support them and I love
him very much. I also eat ass.
Imagine if you got it from your mom and
you're driving on the highway and you're
stuck in bumper to bumper traffic
with ies in front of you for an hour.
We'd laugh.
My mom would laugh.
My mom would get mad at me
for staying in the same lane.
She'll just change Joe Watch.
You're in this lane because you think
it's funny that I have to look at I eat
ass. I didn't say that, mom. I did
not say that. It is funny though.
You think it's funny?
It is very funny.
You'd think it's funny because
my story about that guy,
I know you think it was up.
I think it was more positive than that.
I think he wanted to let people know
that he eats ass because he's got this,
he's got, I don't know if you know him
but we know him. I know him very well.
Jamie and I know him very well,
but he's got this half of his tongue
was bit off by a dog when he was young,
so he knows how to eat.
You go your rough. Yeah,
he's got it wrong at the end of it.
Yeah. He knows how the flipping roof,
he's good at eating this,
but I think people for years where like,
you can't eat ass anymore Mike.
And he was like, fuck you guys man.
What are you trying to say?
Do you know their Florida man story eating
ass man arrested after caught eating
ass inside toys r us store.
That's why they closed down.
That's why they're not in business. That's
a bold move. Little kids in there. Oh,
I know what I saw. It's around
here somewhere. It said thing.
That game is, there's a on the
cover and he's got a hammer.
He's trying to whack the malls and
there's guys in this drug's pool.
Guys eating girls poop. Yeah. Mommy,
you imagine if you saw a dude eating an
asshole underwear in the middle of toys
r us. You're walking around with your
kid. Go and show what your we get,
which should we get a wiffle ball bat?
You want to play wiffle ball? Yeah. Yeah.
Woo Football. Be Fun. Yeah.
And he turned the corner and
then the girl turned,
she was scared out of here.
Well down a rabbit hole with this one.
With ass eating. Yeah. Man.
Who ripped out girlfriends intestines
for yelling her husband's name during sex
gets life in prison. Oh, it
makes perfect sense. What again,
a revolution that's already happening.
We're gonna just gonna change
the way we make babies.
We're going to get away from sex as
the primary mechanism for conceiving.
Our kids will still have sex for
all the great reasons. Uh, we do.
And that's going to open up a
whole new world of a gist of how,
of applying science to what it means
to be a human with a lot of new
possibilities.
That's was going to be so freaking when
people stop having sex to make kids and
they make turns in a lab. Every kid's
mean in the lab when not only that,
I think we're going to move to an era,
an era where people who have,
who make babies through sex
will be seen as taking a risk.
Kind of like people who don't vaccinate
their kids where it's natural.
Tonight it's more natural to not
vaccinate your kids then to do it,
but people say, wait a second, you're
taking on a risk on behalf of your kids.
About 3% of all kids in the world are
born with some kind of harmful genetic
abnormality using in vitro
fertilization and embryo screening.
That 3% can be brought down significantly.
And what happens if you see somebody 20
years from now who has a kid with one of
those preventable diseases? Do you
think that's fate or do you think, well,
wait a second.
Those parents,
they made an ideological decision about
how they wanted to conceive their kids.
I think we're moving towards some
really deep and fundamental changes. Mm.
Similar. Well, yeah, that's a,
that's an interesting conversation of
whether or not you wonder what if we're
ever going to get to a point where
people don't allow people sort of like,
people don't allow people to
not get vaccinated. Right. Know,
like there's a lot of that going on today,
right?
Yeah.
Which is great. Right? You don't
want diseases floating around,
but what if that gets to the place
where we do that with people,
with people creating new life
forms? What have you say, hey,
you are being irresponsible. You just
having sex and having a kid. Yeah,
I know that's your grandma did it.
We don't do it that way in 2099 yeah.
I think it's going to be hard to do that
in a society like the United States,
but in a country like North Korea,
there'll be able to do that. What you are,
or if a country, if they said, look, um,
you can make babies however you want. Um,
but if you make babies the old fashioned
way and if you have some kind of
genetic, your kid has some kind of
genetic disorder that was preventable,
we're just not going to
cover it with insurance.
So you're going to have a
$10 million lifetime bill,
but you don't need to,
you don't need to require something.
You can create an environment where
people's behaviors will change it.
And then there are, there
will be increasing social
pressures. I mean, right now,
you know,
somebody sees some little kid riding
around their bicycle without a helmet.
They're kind of looking at the
parents like, Hey, what are you doing?
How come you don't have
a helmet on your kids?
And I just think that we're moving
toward this kind of societal change where
people will, I believe, see, uh,
conceiving their kids in the lab
as a safer, safer alternative.
And it's not just safety.
Because once you do that,
then that opens you up to the
possibility of all other kinds of,
of applications, of, of technology.
Not just not just to eliminate
risks or prevent disease,
but you have a lot more information.
So already it's possible to active roughly
rank order 15 pre implanted planted
embryos, tallest to shortest
in a decade from highest,
a genetic component of Iq to lowest
genetic component of Iq. I mean,
this stuff is very real
and it's very personal.